with special guest hosts Jason Cheney in  the building  all right okay ladies and gentlemen it's  a Florida dad accused of shooting I  I like to tell them there's one dad and  then reveal the second now  Florida Dad I'm the weather man accused  of shooting each other's daughters in  road rage incident he's he's reacting at  the same time probably driving side by  side and they're having a crazy that is  crazy got it for daughter though right  no they're not that accurate right well  maybe they're trying to shoot each other  in the Mist that's fair trade got two  dads but really you're just one dad  without the beard and one  doing a road races on a Saturday night  so a lot of things happen Saturday  nights  Frank Gilliard 43 so that's a guy also  high speed chase on Highway One raise  your hand if you heard of Highway One  Florida in Florida oh no